they've been public sin for their whole
lives i'm happy that they're able to uh
to have some fun with it and start to
explore themselves even with their
fashion once again angelina and her kids
eternally understood the style
assignment
check out that smile as the proud mama
hit the carpet in a tuxedo gown shiloh
matched mom in black and white with
black flats not sneakers like we saw in
rome zahara chose an off-the-shoulder
pop of yellow vivienne in white maddox
in a suit jacket while knox paired his
with a kiss t-shirt
selma also made a stunning fashion
statement alongside daughter valentina
this is
san lauren
so with my daughters this is my day
tonight i love the color
and it's really comfortable when i
previously interviewed angelina and
salma they gushed over becoming besties
i don't socialize very much and i can
kind of
be a bit heavy i could tell as soon as
she walked in the room she just carries
this warmth we started slowly huh not
like oh we're going to be best friends
it was like an organic thing
and with their daughters all around the
same age could this grow into a
multi-generational sisterhood yeah
valentina and the girls yeah i saw her
and i was like where's shy and z
eternals hits theaters november 5th and
it's breaking down barriers with its
diverse cast
lauren ridloff's character makari is the
first deaf superhero brian tyree henry
brings the first gay superhero fostos to
life you know what's never saved the
planet you're sarcasm when i take my
kids to it
you i
when i was standing with the cast i
think oh z could be makari for halloween
mad could be gilgamesh so it's uh it's
wonderful